mental check - yeah but do your own
mental check [ __ ] snap her talk about
the show dark we haven't talked about it
you're only on the sixth episode you've
never seen it okay so um chairmanship
it's weird because we finished dark the
second time Remmy disappeared we felt
like the show bled into so here's the
deal I was at The Comedy Store now
everyone if you do or do not know Chris
D'Elia
Chris Delia's a guy who doesn't watch
shows he doesn't recommend music he
doesn't recommend anything he does think
he's never come to me and said yeah me
and my girl went to this great
restaurant you should check it out
he's just not that guy honest thing
right so I you know the 12 years I've
known him I've never gotten that from
him so I was at the Comedy Store and we
were peeing next to each other in the
bathroom yeah okay good and he looks
over he's taller and he looks over at my
dick
he goes okay that's pretty good [ __ ]
tall guy right and he goes have you seen
dark look at what my dicks dark dark
it's on that place I go what is it it's
a German show and I love it you should
watch it you'll really like it
I go why it's he goes trust me it's up
your alley so I came home to kalila go
Italian never recommends anything I
think we should give it a go so I
started watching it myself and then
kalila and I started watching it
together and now we got Steve involved
yeah go out what do you mean well the
first episode me nylon II watched and we
weren't too impressed it's good but then
I have to say in Arizona when I saw
episode two the end that's when I I was
hooked
yeah this is because then you realize
well there's so much more to it than
just no no no that's yeah it opened my
horizons I'm like it's mind blowing like
stranger things like you like it
stranger things for adults stranger
things meets interstellar meets kind of
yeah it's really [ __ ] Netflix it's
they went to it's a fruit Germany's
first Netflix show it's produced by them
Netflix it's not something that they
made in Germany and they bought the
rights to it there are the people behind
it so they went to these to show runners
who were happened to be a couple and
they said yeah well we have an idea and
they pitched and they made it it's very
well done but I will say that it's not
one of those shows that you can watch
passively you need hyper ninja focus you
need to pause and then figure out what
you're watching and figure out if you
understand it or if you're following
that's what I had but you know what I
wish I did I wish I had a like a poster
board and me too family trees and time
line it's like Jam of your own terrific
oh yeah deeper deeper larger deal with
different because then you're kind of
unsure as you go and you need
clarification so you have to really
think yeah about oh this person's you
have to remember names and a lot of the
casting they got right you know like
most of it the older guys look like the
childhood selves because it happens at
several different time lines
yeah but sometimes they don't and when
they don't they look nothing like they
did you know as an adult it gets a
little confusing yeah it does it's a
pretty good show you guys really good
show you got to check it out man how do
you think of that I mean the thing that
impressed me is just the whole idea and
the writing and how do you I thought was
pretty creative yeah how do you like in
or link these time line it's yeah it's a
variety in the thinking beyond behind it
is intricate and it blows you'll blow
your mind you know cuz I think you'll
like it
yeah it gets crazy if you're only in the
fifth episode oh my god so it gets more
crazy yes oh good then you're like oh
[ __ ] like it starts to creep it starts
to bleed into your own thoughts because
after Bobby and I watched it all of a
sudden weird things were happening and
we were convinced there was a wormhole
in this house our cat all of a sudden is
waiting outside our door instead of
inside they tell you about that are the
power and a building we've got one
morning this is after we watch me finish
the show yes we get a knock on the door
okay and then I'm sleeping but I can
hear and I hear some guy you guys hear
about an orange cat and climbs like we
have an orange kampot he's in here well
we don't know whose cat this is and then
I hear maybe a week two minutes ago by
and I hear Chloe go scooting our cat our
cat was gone never leaves he's never
left the house in his life how the [ __ ]
did he get out there it was a wormhole
I'm telling you strange wormhole after
the show Remmy was gone twice our cat
all of a sudden appears outside of our
house when the door is locked we live in
an apartment there's no way to get out
of here
well the huge part of the show is like
missing people and then also the power
in the building went out for a whole day
yeah and then all of a sudden our
elevators were acting weird and then the
lights in our kitchen started to flicker
on and off some weird [ __ ] was happening
[Music]